slow down and anti-trumper has an
epiphany and wonders could the idiot be
me New York Times op-ed writer David
Brooks sent shockwaves through the
left-wing establishment this week by
asking a simple question what if we're
the bad guys here we being the elitist
trump-hating liberal ruling class
including the media who thumbed their
nose at everyday Americans and his
latest column Brooks concludes the
answer is yes arguing that he and his
fellow Elite screw so detached from
reality that the rise of trumpism was
inevitable and you can hear the
horrified shrimp forks and espresso cups
dropping from a mile away
he details how the progressive Upper
Crust saw themselves as morally Superior
saviors and that Trump supporters were
just drooling fools writing quote the
ideal that we're all in this together
was replaced with the reality that the
educated class lives in a world up here
and everybody else is forced into a
world down there members of our class
are always publicly speaking out for the
marginalized but somehow we always end
up building systems that serve ourselves
so those same progressives driven by ego
and hungry for power now dominate the
media politics and major corporations
cluelessly lecturing while their Cities
Burn pushing the defunding of police and
murdering America's most popular beer by
hiring a gibbering goofball in his skirt
yeah
Brooks added quote like all Elites we
use language to recognize one another
and exclude others using words like
problematic cisgender Latin X and
intersectional is a sure sign that
you've got cultural capital coming out
of your ears meanwhile members of the
less educated classes have to walk on
eggshells because something that was
sayable five years ago now gets you
fired so when Trump came along offering
a voice to the voiceless he became the
threat but now they're getting a taste
of their own medicine and shockingly for
saying what he said David Brooks has yet
to be snatched from the street and
stuffed into a windowless van or
murdered by Hillary Clinton
but you know the night is still young
Dagan why is he admitting this now
what's driving this realization by the
way this he just explained what Tyra
said in the last block
I hate this article I forgot because
number one he is speaking to the super
Elites and they are hearing what he's
preaching and let me explain myself
by the very fact that I'm exploring this
I just that I'm even pondering that we
might be bad guys that makes me and us
not just good guys but super great guys
that I am having this moment of
self-reflection but this is not lasting
because at the end of the day they are
all
ponderous condescending Pricks and they
will always be that
all right he dismisses at the end of the
piece he's dismisses the entire premise
Trump needs to go to jail and he asks
the question when will we ever stop
behaving in ways that make trumpism
inevitable uh never because uh in the
article he goes into how how few people
uh 0.8 percent of college graduates
graduate from the super Elite 12 schools
do you know what
two-thirds of people in this country
don't have college degrees that's the
two-thirds of the nation that you are
utterly dismissing and then the poultry
little free time that working Americans
have they have two questions you've got
enough ice and did you fill her up
that's all that America cares about all
right Tyrus
care to add anything
I I pride myself in always filling her
up
what pour a glass what
high class entries
Pete you know what I'm talking about
exactly you don't want a half empty cup
look you gotta pour it in yeah you got
to pour it in you know
half empty cup with guests over that's
embarrassing not in my household I won't
have it good sir you have manner you
know I I I I can relate to
what the good man is trying to say is
it's like having a narcissistic mother
you know do I love too much did I try
too hard
was my
wanting you to have decorum and look
good at school just too much for you so
that's what this is that's what Dagan is
saying it's like they're and if it
wasn't for me being so giving and just
virtuous and perfect
the Slime never would have came in but
the I can't compete with the the
ugliness and the evil because it is hard
to be this way and you can't
and I've done everything I could for you
Pete not my fault but it's not my fault
yeah it's my fault for loving you too
much even though you're a deplorable yes
cat did you read the article and feel
the same way
well okay so I'm not a liberal I'm also
not a conservative I do know how it
feels to have people just who are gonna
hate you no matter what you do and at a
certain point you're like should I kill
myself like you don't want to just keep
listening to them and I think that a lot
of these people the way they see Trump
is that if you voted for Trump you're a
bad person it doesn't mean if you
support everything he does or even I
will still get it from people because I
work here well I'm associating with
people who voted for Trump so that makes
me a bad person and it's like you're
normalizing Trump it's like dude half of
the country voted for this guy right so
how can you say You're a worthless
irredeemable human being for you know
seeing half the country is also being
human and that makes you a good person
get over yourself yes yes we're just
being honest like how does it drives me
insane and they see themselves as good
people it's like no you're not you don't
want to do the work for improving
yourself so you want to take what you
already are and try to spin that and be
oh that makes me so much better than
everyone else you're not better than
anybody Pete you're better than
everybody everyone
's superficial I I was driving we were
driving back from a week at the at the
beach where I was using my self tanner
yeah what are you wearing uh it's called
the sun Greg check it out
and my wife is reading this article
because I was driving kids were yelling
and it's amazing you read it you go oh
wow he's really he's he's getting it oh
okay he's David Brooks the anti-trumper
who used to be a conservative by the way
he's written this column for years
bashing Trump maybe this is a conversion
moment and then three the last three
paragraphs is you all are idiots it is
it's easy to understand why people in
the less educated class would cling to
Trump I'd love the last line though when
we when will we stop behaving in ways
that make trumpism inevitable they can't
their systems don't work they fence
themselves away from the criminality
lawlessness that they endorse and then
they wonder why everyone else is pissed
off about it yeah so of course they're
going to keep creating Trump and I I
guess I think this is why to give a nod
to my kids who are yelling in the back
this is why Trump is the goat this is
why Trump is the goat No Cap you won't
see many athletes resting in sports
without drug testing hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else